ANTHONY: The history of
5.301, right here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
IKE: It's over.
And I miss it already.
NARRATOR: It's the last
day of 5.301.
Next week, everybody will turn
in their lab reports.
And the week after that, they'll
all pass the class.
IKE: I came with no
lab experience.
This is my first ever lab.
ETHAN: I didn't have any
research experience coming
here at MIT, at least
in the sciences.
LINA: In the beginning,
I understood nothing.
IKE: I learned a lot.
I actually knew the whole
theoretical part of it.
But I was always interested in
getting to know this part too.
LEALIA: And I learned a lot
about chem lab techniques.
IKE: I got a hang of it.
Starting, I was really bad.
You could asK Phil or anyone.
LINA: As I've progressed in
this class, I think I've
gotten a lot better.
NARRATOR: It's been a journey
for everyone.
But it's not all about
the science.
LINA: The best thing
about 5.301 was
getting to meet the people.
It was really, really fun.
ETHAN: It was a lot of fun.
DAN: I had a ton of fun
in lab, meeting
everyone, making friends.
ETHAN: We really bonded a lot
in those three weeks.
LEALIA: I'm going to miss the
class and the atmosphere.
HANSOL: Everybody's talking
to each other.
And we're all getting
to know each other.
And we're all loud.
ETHAN: The spirit of
5.301 will live on.
NARRATOR: The chemistry
department is getting a few
more majors this year.
DAN: Taking this lab class
especially strengthened my
desire to pursue chemistry.
ANTHONY: I actually switched
my major from chemical
engineering to chemistry.
I think it was the right
choice for me.
After 5.301, I realized that I
really did like being in lab.
I do have a strong passion for
chemistry in that I could do
it for the rest of my life.
NARRATOR: Hansol doesn't
know it yet.
But she'll declare chemistry
as well.
At the end of the day, Dr.
Dolhun meets with every
student individually to
say good bye and help
them find a UROP lab.
EMILY: He just wanted to say
that he enjoyed having us and
asked us what our plans
were for our majors
and stuff like that.
ANTHONY: I just talked to him
about how the class was, what
I was thinking about doing.
And he was letting me know that
he'll be here to help us,
read our drafts of emails
to professors and stuff.
NARRATOR: And just a few weeks
later, Emily, Hansol, and Ike
all have UROPs.
EMILY: The research that I'm
doing in the Essigmann lab is
we are looking at some
chlorouracil derivatives.
And we're putting these
lesions inside DNA.
And we're testing it to see if
it causes any mutations.
And this can lead to diabetes
and cancer.
We're studying this just to
locate exactly what each
lesions do and how they
affect the body.
HANSOL: Hi, I'm in lab.
The whole purpose of what I'm
doing is to figure out how
fast we can make peptide
Fmoc chemistry.
And right now, I'm currently
designing an experiment to
take a peptide at room
temperature and compare it
with how it couples under a
microwave at 60 degrees, which
is the optimal temperature.
IKE: I got a UROP.
Yeah, so they delivered
on their promise.
It's working with metal organic
frameworks, or MOFs,
which are really well structured
organic molecules.
The most important
thing was 5.301.
I took that.
It was like, all right, this
guy is prepared, you know?
See ya.
I'm out.
Monday, I wake up at
2:00 PM, yeah.
NARRATOR: 5.301 was tough.
But Anthony, Lina, Ike,
Emily and the
others met the challenge.
IKE: Don't feel intimidated.
You're still here, right?
You still made it.
Make the best of
what you have.
You're just like
everyone else.
You're as smart as
That's why you're here.
You're here for a purpose.
So do your thing, study
hard, and you'll pass.
I won't guarantee an A though.
But you'll pass.
PHIL: Oh no, don't film this.